after ramping up the possibility for
weeks of a russian invasion of ukraine
the white house on wednesday downgraded
that threat from president vladimir
putin saying an invasion is no longer
imminent i use that once i think others
have used that once and then we stopped
using it because i think it sent in
a message that we weren't intending to
send which was that we knew that
president putin had made a decision
still the united states is sending more
troops to eastern europe
some of the forces will be repositioned
to romania others will be coming from
the united states to poland and germany
it's a response to president putin who
has positioned tens of thousands of
troops inside russia near ukraine's
border it's important that we send a
strong signal to mr putin and frankly to
the world that nato matters to the
united states it matters to our allies
and we have ironclad article 5
commitments an attack on one is an
attack on all
the roughly 3 000 troops will bolster
the nato presence in europe and are in
addition to the 8 500 u.s troops put on
standby last month by u.s president joe
biden the united states maintains
diplomacy as the best path to resolving
security disagreements russia wants
assurances nato will halt expansion into
former soviet republics like ukraine but
the west won't provide that guarantee
instead bidens promised severe
consequences if putin invades he has
shown no signs of being interested or
willing to de-escalate the tensions the
u.s forces will reinforce nato's eastern
flank working with host countries as
nato has not yet activated its response
force to counter what it refers to as
russian aggression i think there's a
bargaining
aspect to what they're doing which is to
put something on the table that can be
taken away
a chit if you will in exchange for
russian
non-aggression against ukraine despite
no new russian threat and no signs of an
imminent invasion of ukraine the
pentagon says the movement of troops
could begin soon
and there could be the possibility of
even more troop movements in the future
kimberly hellcat al jazeera washington